my name is gwagyeong Wong and I'm
engineer a confluent and a PMC member of
Kafka and today I'm going to talk about
Kafka and the rise of stream processing
so you see that we have two keywords
here in my title Kafka and the stream
processing and I would like to start
with the second keyword and ask a
question about what is not stream
processing okay the claim I want to make
here is that stream processing is not
necessarily transient approximate or
lossy although although we have actually
seen multiple you know papers or systems
from literature as well as industry
talking about like one pass algorithms
in stream processing or how you can make
you know at least once a delivery in
stream processing I might claim here is
that it's not so very not necessarily
the case that you need some batch
processing as a safety net of against
stream processing to me stream
processing is just a new programming
diagram where you treat your include
data not as a finite data set but I
could as a continuous data streams that
you process them as soon as they occur
so to illustrate this idea of stream
processing as a new programming paradigm
I would like to go through some of the
commonly known program paradigms
the first one is request and response
right this is a pure synchronous
programming model where you send one
input at a time as a request to your
servers and the server is respond with a
risk with an output right so this is
like one input and one output out if you
want to scale our such model of course
you have to skew up the number of
services because of the synchronous
programming pattern that you had with
request and response and on other
extremes and other extreme of the
programming you have batch processing in
batch processing you don't have this
synchronous processing model but instead
you will wait for a batch of includes to
be available and then you'll send them
to your computers or to your servers and
after a while all your outputs become
available right it not only gives you
like hi
performance but also give you this nice
decoupling from where you generate your
input data to where you start to process
and consume them but one of one other
side of this issue is that you now have
this latency from where the data was
originally created to where to when the
data was being processed because you
need to wait a whole batch to be
completed so stream processing but I
mean personally I will it as something
that sits in between of two extreme
models where at the same time it is also
a asynchronous programming model you
don't have like one input and one output
but I understand you also bring your
data to your computers instead of wait
for your computer wait for your data to
be complete before you start processing
them right so you can have like each one
of your input can be one or more input
points and they can be processed as soon
as they become available to your
computers and in such a programming
model there are a couple you know very
important trade-off decisions that you
users you need to make like latency cost
and correctness for example if you are
building a online building system in
terms of like against a log processing
system you may want to actually pay more
attention to your correctness to have
very actual results and you may actually
be willing to pay more cost for that and
similarly if you are building a
real-time alert system you may actually
pay more attention into latency but if
you are building a ETL process system
you may not be paying too much in terms
of that so the one essence of streaming
processing is that it should allow users
to have the flexibility to specify those
different tweet of dimensions while
developing their real-time tasks so just
a very first recap of what is stream
processing
I think Street rehearsing is just a new
programming paradigm that bring
computations to unbound a data instead
I'll bring data to computations and it
has trade-off between latency kragnes
and cost so if you can leave
talk with a couple of takeaways I hope
this one will be the first takeaway that
you can take so now let's go back to the
first keyword
why is Kafka in this big picture of
stream processing right and to answer
that I would like to ask similarly a
slightly different question and what is
Kafka really if you ask different people
who is already using Kafka or who at
least have heard about Kafka they may
actually give you different answers
someone it how do I actually Kafka is
like a scalable pub/sub messaging system
but you know sometimes they told you
it's like a real-time data pipeline to
solve a very common problem where you
want to make your data that is generated
from point A which is like your online
servers or your online data stores to be
available to be processed as soon as
possible
in another point and sometimes the
retreat's Kafka as like a distributed
and the replicated log where you can
actually build your online storage and
have like chill replications using Kafka
as its underlying replication layer and
sometimes you also heard people talking
about Kafka as a unified data
integration stack as against - like the
so called lambda architecture where you
can use it as a persistent buffer so
that you don't need help like
complicated to lay so two layers systems
to build your software stack I can just
use Kafka as a source of choose to pipe
your streams of data so which one of
those definitions is correct and my
answer is that it's actually all of them
Kafka you can think of it as a streaming
platform which you can not only publish
and subscribe your records as data
streams into and out of it and you can
also use it to store those streams of
Records as the source of truth but also
to process them and react to them as
soon as those streams of Records become
available in Kafka and today I will
focus on the process story of Kafka and
and then drill deeper into what is
really Kafka for stream processing
okay so when we talk about stream
processing with Kafka there are a common
sort of like common practices already
existing with it the first option is you
call the DIY option where you can
actually use the producer and consumer
client of Kafka to process your data
well feelings consumers to fetch them in
real time and after the data is
transformed is clean or is enriched you
can then use a producer to send them
back to Kafka or to any other third
party systems but the DIY stream
processing is hard right you not only
have to consider how you can code you
are processing logic you also need to
consider other issues like how you can
how you deliver ordering how you do
state management and how you do
partitioning and stability all kinds of
those hard issues right now the second
option is that you can actually use a
layered architecture and use a
full-fledged stream processing framework
on top of Kafka which will basically
handle all those detail that works for
you so that programmers can just focus
on their computational logic and
examples of those frameworks like storm
spark fleeing or Santa write the list
can go on and one one common problem I
would say for those frameworks that they
actually can be a hire another layer on
top of Kafka which requires you to build
up those clusters in order to process
your data and different other systems
have their own aspects in terms of how
you config your stream processing
frameworks how you leverage on resource
management are you own are you bound to
use yarn or missiles and how you
actually can deploy such systems along
with Kafka in your software stack so you
may ask this question okay I want to
have this full fledge system but can
actually just customize my own
management or come fix to do those kind
of processing so here comes the third
option that I want to talk about today
which is we have a lightweight stream
processing library just like the
producer and consumer
client libraries which actually allow
you to deploy your real-time
applications using those libraries just
like the way you deploy your web servers
using the producer or consumer libraries
and still have the powerful
functionalities to do all kinds of
stream processing tasks
so the Kafka streams which is a third
stream circle and rivalry beside the
producer and consumer which is
introduced in the old term version which
is I think this August is just such like
a library which is powerful yet easy to
use it is a part of the Apache Kafka
project and it has all kinds of
different features like event of event
at a time processing state management
and distributed and a fault tolerance
and I will talk about details about
those features and it can be actually
deployed in any way you can go up to a
data center using your favorite
deployment model or you can just run it
in your own laptop just like a you know
a normal java application and again just
like what you have experience with your
other Kafka clients like producer and
consumer you can just use Kafka stream
client at the same way to just depend on
this library and start coding your
applications with it and you can use
different kinds of resource management
and from you know the very uncool - very
cool frameworks by the way this spectrum
is purely dependent on the personal
preference of my teammate Michael so if
you have strong feelings against the
spectrum I can give you his contact
information and you can talk to him
about that the key point of the library
of Khafre streams is that we believe the
simple is beautiful right you don't want
to have a very power I'm not only a very
powerful programming model but yet it
has to be very simple to use in term of
programming but also for operations so
this is the DSA are I will maybe only
take very few minutes to talk about the
programming model of it
but here it is the vseo of Kafka streams
you can create a source stream by
reading from a specific Kafka topic here
with M whole topic topic 1 and then you
can transform these streams and create
new ones like aggregations futuring
joins and then eventually you can send
your result streams back into Kafka or
you can actually send us with Austrian
into some other third party existence as
well and finally just like the way you
will start your producer clients you can
then start your streams client with the
with a specified computational logic as
well as a configuration and start them
as a normal job application so that that
is all I want to talk about programming
right now I want to drill deep into how
you actually will make operations of
Khafre streams because we believe that
you know API and coding is just one part
of the whole story you also need to pay
much attention in terms in terms of how
you would add apart your programs how
you troubleshoot when they have issues
and again here we believe that a simple
is beautiful the key idea of Kafka
streams is that it will try to leverage
the Kafka brokers as much as possible to
solve those difficult problems and for
those of you who are not familiar with
Kafka broker internals here is a very
quick overview of Kafka itself socata
brokers store your data as a log where
messages are appended into the tail of
the log by the producer and the
consumers can then start reading from
the log based on their logical offsets
as they are appended so both of the
reads and writes are lot are CC are
sequential on your persistent disks and
in terms of scalability we can then
partition your logs into different
shards or we call it partitions and have
different
broker machines to host those partitions
so that when you want to skill your
Kafka brokers you can just add more
machines into your Kafka cluster and
then further partition your topics to be
produced and consumed by more and more
of those crimes so the Kafka's dreams
leverage on the kafka brokers such that
it defines a stream just like a key
value pair of a stream of key value pair
records and you can see that each one of
these records can correspond to a
message in the remote cafe brokers and
when you specify your computational
logic the Kafka stream library is
internally building this computational
logic as a dag we call it as a processor
topology and each dag as has thoughts
that is connected by those streams as
key value records and then each of those
dots we call them as stream processors
and when you specify your logic using
the DSL the such a dag is automatically
constructed when you specify different
steps by transforming your input and the
intermediate streams and finally you
send them back to Kafka there are two
special types of processors in the
topology the source processor is you
only used for reading data from the
Kafka Brokers they don't have any so
called income streams or parent parent
processors because they are only cutting
data from Kafka to the downstream
processors and the sink processor on the
other hand only have income streams but
no outcome streams because they are used
to pipe data back into Kafka as well so
when you run your Kafka streams
application the source processors will
continuously pipe data from the Kafka
logs the records will trend we are
traverse the whole topology and
eventually the sink processor was
sending back into Kafka logs and you can
run your Kafka streams either co-located
with a broker's but more commonly they
will be running on two different
machines just like the way you run your
producer and consumer client and then if
you want to skill your you know your
Kafka streams application the easiest
way is that you can just start you are
seeing you are the same
she's of the same piece of code of Kafka
streams on two different grads or two
different machines and they will
actually automatically balance the work
by assigning different partitions of
their input topics to different
instances of those applications and when
you want to skill up your application
you can simply add more partitions into
your input topics and then start the
same piece of code are more threads or
machines which can then type data from
those added partitions as well so the
next topic I want to talk about is how
you manage your states in a stream
processing application there are two
kinds of operators eating stream
processing right you have future you
have map or you have flat map all of
them are so called stateless operations
you have one input and you have one
output or multiple ones but you don't
keep record of the reason was and there
are other states for operators like
joints and aggregations where as you
need some kind of a state store to keep
track of those intermediate results in
order to complete such or computational
operators and in practice people usually
have two strategies to basically
establish those stay stores one one
option is that you can actually use some
remote stores where your stream
processors will basically talk to them
well they need to read or write data to
those stores and but of course because
those stores are remote you may need to
pay high latency in terms of the
round-trip so that you also have to
maybe consider how you can handle
concurrency and all kinds of things to
have isolated of Xoom processors on the
other hand people have also considered
using so-called local state stores where
the state stores can be just co-located
with your stream processors as they are
reading and writing data from it it
gives you faster access but also better
isolation of your state stores and that
when you take a look at the global view
of those states you can just aggregate
each one of those web charts of your
local states and you actually have the
global
stay store views so Katherine streams
took the second approach where basically
when you have those stateful operations
such as like aggregate or joins they
will automatically create those state
stores locally so that they can be
leveraged to complete such operators and
when you have multiple ones of such
instances you will each one of those
topology or instance will have their own
state stores that can be read and write
and also create externally so when I
talk about curries inter externally this
is what I actually meant for that I
think you have a common practice where
you will use for example a stream
processing library or stream presenting
framework to do your data for likeliness
or enrichment with all kinds of
transformation and you do like
aggregations and you dump your results
into external systems and then you can
let other applications or other teams in
your company to query them but with
kafka streams you can actually have a
bunch of api's but other applications
not maybe you by yourself can query
those day stores directly so that you
can you do not need to necessarily
establish those external systems in
order to have queries so I'm not saying
that you should not use you know HBase
or Cassandra a kudu to do all kind of
things but the point here is that with
Kafka out of the box it should give you
these functionalities to do what you
need in terms of streaming your data and
do street real-time analytics alerting
monitoring on all kind of things so when
you actually take a look at the DSL here
you mean realize that you have two types
of you know first first reasons and
classes in the England easier one is
called a k stream where you can read it
from say a Kafka topic or you can
transform it from another stream and you
also have a so called K table where you
can get from a stateful operations so
what is the K table here I want to talk
a little bit more or switch my gears and
to talk about one key observations when
we design kafka streams which is that
you're right
between a stream and a table so the
observation is the following if you take
a streams of updates and each update is
basically saying okay for this tuple
this value is updated to those those
fields are updated to these tables you
can actually replay this stream of
change logs to build your tables or
States from the stream and similarly if
you have such a evolving States you can
actually reconstruct the stream of
change logs well you are updating your
state stores as well so the state store
itself or the tables can be actually
thought about as a materialized view of
your underlying stream of change log
records so this kind of duality we call
it the stream as actually a change log
of table and table as a materialized
view of stream has actually been
leveraged in in the database literature
as well already and we are using this
obligation to these lines of a table and
the case stream has two kinds of
different streams the case stream
interprets as a record stream where each
record is a pure key and value pairs
whereas in a k table it is also a stream
but it's actually a changelog stream
where a new record where the same key is
treated as an overwrite of a previous
record with the same key so to
illustrate that let me give you two
examples of a case stream and a capable
stream so the case stream you can think
about it for example as a purchase
history where you have Alice bought eggs
and Bob bought values and Alice Bob milk
right it's basically a record indicating
what has happened or what are the events
in your stream and k table you can think
about it as like a profile updates
stream so if you look at a one-time
snapshot of those streams basically it
tells you for example in this case
stream case Alice have bought X and
Alice in now work at LinkedIn if you
apply more records in those two
different kinds of streams in the
records
Jim layer it tells you that Alice has
bought ax and milk whereas in the table
of chinlock stream it tells you that
Ally is now working at Microsoft no
longer in LinkedIn so it's actually an
overwrite of a previous record so we
apply different operators in those two
kinds of streams it actually also gave
you two different semantics for example
if you aggregate our case stream it
basically gives you the Sun when you see
we will see records with the same key
whereas if you have doing at a table
aggregation it basically gives you the
overrides of a previous value because
it's basically it's a change lower
extreme so that each newer record is
actually not aggregating to the previous
one but overriding the previous record
and we have operators that allows you to
basically do transformations that is
actually from a stream to a table and
from a table to a stream here but
remember a K table here is really not a
table it's just a change rock stream
that can be materialized at a state
store and when you for example have
updates into your aggregation operators
you basically are as I show you here
let's say if you have a new record from
one of your input streams it will first
bypass the join operators so that the
intermediary stream here will have a new
regular pended and then when you go
through the aggregations it HAP will
have a new record that is overriding the
previous record in the change off stream
at the same time the state store will
also be app updated as your current
snapshot of the materialized view so
well what about for tolerance will you
talk about state stores so remember that
we have this duality between a table and
a stream and we also leverage this
observation to build our fault tolerance
mechanisms the idea here is that we
again use Kafka to maintain your change
log streams where you are updating your
state's the change log streams can be
think about as the source of choose of
your all your updates into your state's
so that whenever you have application
field or you need have some upgrade path
so that you need to roll in bounds your
streams application
you can first migrate those tasks to
other machines actually the library will
do this automatically for you and then
upon resuming your tasks they will first
read from the change log to restore your
current states and then you can continue
the processing from where you have left
and a similarly for reprocessing story
I'd say if you have about discovered
well your stream processing task is
running or you want to update your
application like logic like if you are
under a be testing scenario all you'll
need to do is to restart a new
application with a brand empty state
stores and replace your incoming streams
as well as you are changing our streams
after it has caught up with your own
application you can then do the
switchover and a continue from there
okay another very important concept in
stream processing is time it's basically
because in stream processing you can't
have a goal of view of your data set
because it's unbounded you have to
basically have this time notion to
reason about the time variance or how
you basically handle late arrival data
for example the two are very common
concept of time in stream processing is
event high which indicates when is this
event or this key value pair recording
Afghan streams really happens and this
processing time which indicates when the
stream processing library is a client
really has processed this record and why
this distinction is important well
because you may have out of ordering or
you have late arrival data based on two
different but based on different notions
of time right if you take with ample the
Star Wars series at example here I would
like to use like the event time as the
time where the each story really happens
in this table world where at this
processing time you can think about it
as the time when it was really filmed of
this story you can see that there is
really a lot of ordering in those
streams in those two kinds of different
notions and depending on which time
notion you take in your streaming
application you are streaming
applications it may actually give you
different
no different results so in contrast
dreams we allow you to allow users to
basically associate a timestamp for each
of those key value pairs through a class
called the timestamp extractor you can
free them post stamp your record using
the current work long time as your
processing time or you can just extract
the time handsome field from the Kafka
message as your event I which is maybe
stand by the producer client when this
record is originally created or for
example if your time is in your value
payload you can also extract it you in
this time some extractor api's - time -
to stamp your records so one important
use of those times is when you have
those windowing operators for example if
you are having a running window
aggregations of your streams and based
on the time stamp our records you may
actually want to put put it in two
different window buckets when you do the
aggregations so for example here when
you actually have a record whose time is
it engaging it's coming from a late
future in your stream you don't want to
actually put it in your current bucket
but you won't actually put it in a very
future bucket so that you will have the
right right examples and similarly as
you move along when you have actually a
late records from like whose time stamp
here it's green actually it indicates
it's coming from the history you can
actually put it to the its corresponding
bucket so that the aggregates the
counting can be updated okay so those
are like the hard parts I have covered
while you are doing it with a DIY
approach where compared with what kafka
stream library can give you but I would
I would recommend you to read more
details about all those all those
technical challenges through our web
dogs and again the key observation here
or key idea here is that we don't we not
only want to make this library to be
powerful but also we want to make to
make it very simple to use because if as
a programming
swimmer programming interface it is not
easy to use no matter how powerful it is
it is really not a successful system so
that is about how you would process your
data in Kafka as long as they become
available
but how can you get your data into Kafka
if the data is like in other systems one
option you can have is the so-called
Kafka connect framework which is also
included in the Apache Kafka in a recent
release this February it actually is a
framework which allow you to program
your ingress or egress pipelines from
other systems into and out of Kafka you
know very easy way and since its first
introduced in this February we have
actually collected more than 40
connectors coded under this framework
from the open source community and some
of them is contributed by comfort
ourselves or our partners but more are
actually from the whole community
they cover systems like my sequel
cassandra elasticsearch where you can
easily use those connectors to basically
pipe data in and out of Kafka to those
systems so going back to the big picture
of Kafka as a streaming platform what I
want to emphasize here is that as a lot
of box solution
Kafka can actually allow you to
basically do all kinds of real-time
functionalities such as piping your data
and process them in real time with the
system as a business system as a whole
well I'm not saying that you do not need
to have any other system to build a
layered architecture but the whole point
here is that with Kafka out of box it
should give you enough functionalities
so that you can actually use it as a
bare minimum of functionality before you
consider actually adding more systems
having the operations over those and
this test to illustrate this idea as I
mentioned here you can use again the
producer and consumer clients to
basically use data into Kafka or write
them and you can use the connect
frameworks to pipe them from different
data stores
and eventually you can use streams
Stream Klein to process them as soon as
those records are piped into Kafka so
that will be the end of my talk so two
takeaways the first is a way as I
mentioned before is that stream
processing is not necessarily transient
or lossy it's just a new programming
paradigm that allows you to process your
data as soon as they become available
and with the newly added clients a
stream client into Kafka we believe not
people cannot find it much easier to
build a real-time stream applications
with Kafka if you want to learn more
about Kafka I would like to recommend
you to read the the open webinar series
about how to build your software stack
over Kafka and how to offer them and if
you are already a user of Kafka and not
willing to share your experience
operating it we have the coming Kafka
Summit Series next year we have two
venues in New York City and San
Francisco and I would love to hear your
proposals about your talks to talk about
your usage in Kafka so that will be the
end of my talk ah thank you
[Applause]
I'm four questions okay so the the api's
lab we have exposed in Kafka streams in
that for each K table whenever you
decide to materialize it okay
you can have a store name when you
basically store that in your state
stores and as long as you actually the
other users are aware of the store names
you can you can they can leverage
through the exposed api's to query those
running Kafka system application through
the store store names as the parameters
but the first the the first thing is
that as long as again you have the store
names yet have you can do that
you know fall torrents and how you catch
up to all data and reprocess them this
is a little bit more basic question
because I don't know too much of capita
how much of data is kept in the
changelog and how do you control that
the question is how much data is history
so if you're if you are familiar with
like whether high login database like
war login database basically the change
log can be just think about as a right
ahead log in your data stores where each
updates can is captured as a record or a
message in your Kafka Chinua profit so
that by just replaying this log you will
have of you will have a full view of
your snapshot my question was how do you
control how much of the history is kept
well in Kafka there are multiple ways to
control how you want to retain your data
remember you can retain your data by
size like you want to return like up to
500 gigabyte of their data you can also
return your data by time with them you
can say that I want to return my topics
for seven days or some of them I want to
return them for even longer but also
Khafre have a log compaction feature
which basically is used for the changes
on top itself a lot of compaction kicks
in Parata clay which will basically
obsolete those old records as long as
there's a new record with the same key
so the same the same idea as how you
will basically apply them to overwrite
your state stores so with log compaction
we will basically also shrink the size
of your there are logs